[Música]
ah
i
yo les voy a pedir que les aplaudamos
mucho más fuerte porque ya son muy
chiquitos
quizás son famosos
[Aplausos]
me gustaría que nos cuenten cómo fue que
surgió esta idea qué fue lo que los
motivó a hacer este trabajo
el centro de producción audiovisual de
la uni
y necesitaban estaban en busca de
estudiantes que tengan conocimiento
sobre las energías renovables que
quieran actuar que quieran participar y
llegaron al colegio con esta propuesta
un lindo proyecto donde nosotros
adicionamos y quedamos seleccionados
para poder actuar
guau lo que es ser ser artista actor
qué lugares visitaron por qué lugares se
anduvieron de nuestra patagonia para
filmar este trabajo bueno estuvimos en
madrid en el parque de anuales también
estuvimos en rawson en el parque de
ingeniería y también anduvimos por otros
lugares también visitando el parque y pf
el de capsa y el de pan américa muy bien
y quien los acompaña que personas de la
universidad los acompañan en este
proyecto nos acompaña el director
horacio junto al equipo de audiovisuales
y también nuestro director del taller de
energías renovables
paula de marín ahora sí les cuento que
está acá allá el fondo y les voy a pedir
un fuerte aplauso para el que me impulsa
que acompaña a todos estos jóvenes y
listos
hablamos en el break que seguramente
esto signifique para ellos un antes y un
después en sus vidas
saben una cosa este documental se va a
llamar se llama ya herederos del viento
y de los del viento porque eligieron
este nombre para este trabajo
herederos porque somos tenemos una
herencia patagónica a nosotros somos
herederos de la huella que dejaron
nuestros bisabuelos nuestros abuelos
nuestros antepasados
en torno a lo que son las energías
alternativas también porque hace muchos
años que se explota lo que es la energía
no renovable en la región pero también
está esta cosa del viento la ciudad del
viento que todos bueno creo que la
mayoría no le debe gustar pero se puede
aprovechar de una manera increíble y
bueno que ha demostrado en el documental
como a través de los años
se pudo
y se pudieron crear se pudieron abrir
las puertas a la energía renovable que
es increíble
entonces quiere decir que el innombrable
la mayoría casa de quién es el
innombrable no para muchos
qué palabra tienen para decirles a todas
estas personas que los están escuchando
y todos los que nos van a escuchar los
que lo están los que los que los están
viendo por streaming qué palabra tienen
para que empiecen a reconciliarse con
nuestro viento
es increíble
[Aplausos]
bueno hay que empezar a llevarse mejor
porque es el futuro de esto así que hay
que empezar a utilizar bien las energías
renovables el viento nuestro futuro y
nuestro futuro de lana vigo
[Música]
ah
y